this is ed glazer he's a film historian
with a peculiar specialty i
talk about highlight and uh occasionally
re-release foreign rip-offs and remakes
remakes like turkish rambo nigerian
titanic and even egyptian rocky horror
picture show but there's one that stands
out from the rest the holy grail of
these kinds of films is chatting
inaudible the man who saves the world
better known as the turkish star wars
turkish star wars is a 1980s action film
that tells the story of two turkish
space adventurers who crash land on a
desert planet and decide to overthrow
its evil tyrannical ruler i never really
seen anything like it
it's a little bit like
a fever dream
and it's famous for well this
it's called trigger star wars not
because of the plot but because it
actually lifts footage from star wars to
sell the illusion that they're flying
fighters in space
[Music]
when the film was in theaters only a
handful of prints were made and given
that there was virtually no film
preservation in turkey at the time every
copy was thought to have been destroyed
but after decades in obscurity media
reports surfaced of a rogue
projectionist who kept the only existing
copy of the film in his personal
collection ed made it his mission to
restore the film to its glory
once i got hold of the film i got in
touch with a company who was very very
excited about scanning and preserving it
obviously it's 30 years old it's in a
little bit rough shape what i want to be
able to do is restore it to the best
possible condition and ideally in front
of as many people's eyes as i possibly
can
yeah but why go through all this trouble
for turkish star wars it's so
unique
visually it's so
lurid and vivid and wild and crazy and
there's just nothing else like it
the first time i saw it was on a screen
this big
now i want to see it on the big screen
the way that it was in 1982. how do you
say may the force be with you in turkish
[Music]
you